[Music]
2020 has proven to be a year of
reckoning for america's cities
coveted 19 and protests in the streets
have prompted some to predict the demise
of america's cities
well i can assure you that metropolitan
life is here to stay
the opportunities in american cities for
young people immigrants and
entrepreneurs
are simply too strong cities always
bounce back
cities like austin denver and nashville
show that urban life can be economically
diverse
affordable and community oriented and
yet there are obstacles
the stasis of elite interests has
manifested itself in cronyism
widespread nimbyism and heavy-handed
regulatory power
most importantly urban policymakers must
not only make housing affordable
they need affordable neighborhoods that
are well-rounded with the amenities that
make urban life vibrant
burdensome zoning and land use
regulations have proven to be major
inhibitors to housing and mobility
and where mayors have relaxed them more
people can afford a good place to live
while there are challenges perpetuating
america's entrepreneurial spirit is up
to a new generation of leaders who
understand that our cities
are at the core of america's dynamism do
you think new york will keep its
position
as america's cultural and financial
center in 2021 and beyond
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to like and subscribe
for more research and videos from aei